I think that there are certainly
tensions there are certainly some
skepticism and I think you know there
are some young people who wish the old
folks would stop talking about back in
the day but that's true of all young
people when they talk to old people
right it's not just a true of our
community it's true of all communities
but one thing that I think is important
understanding is that there have been
there are generations in our community
right and thank God for that right one
of the things that's so tragic about the
LGBT communities that we have a
generation many of whom were lost to the
AIDS crisis and so unlike a lot of
communities I think something that's
very specific to our community is that
you know we have the Stonewall
generation that was there that
participated in the protest that were
part of that early uprising of Gay
Liberation that early feeling of
liberation that came out of that
movement and then there was a period of
time where we lost a lot of our brothers
and sisters especially our brothers to
the AIDS to AIDS and there is a pain
there and there are scars there that are
that it will never go away nor should
they so this idea that we are always
kind of free and all this progress has
been made and that the young people in
this generation that are coming up now
have no worries right the fact amader is
there actually rising STD rates and
rising HIV infection rates in certain
segments of this generation particularly
among young men of color young men in
the african-american and Latino
communities there are rising HIV rates
among this members of this generation
there are all sorts of considerations
that and struggles that this generation
has to has to work with and so and and
and the progress that's been made will
will yield its own struggles right i
mean you know it's one thing to struggle
to earn the right to marry it's another
thing to struggle to make your marriage
work right then once we have the right
to marry then we got to actually marry
each other and make it work and that's
not easy right nobody has ever been
married will ever tell you that I mean
what's the biggest crisis of the the
worst thing that's happened as a result
of the goodrich decision in
Massachusetts is that the goodrich's got
divorced right you know and at you I
feel badly for them but the end of the
day
like that court ruling was named after a
lesbian couple that were heralded as
heroines of our movement and they should
have been they were very very important
but they're now divorced right so that's
its own struggle is to figure out how to
make families how to make our families
work how to marry each other and love
each other and stay true to each other
and that's that's a human struggle right
that's a human struggle that transcends
all histories in all communities and
it's one that this generation is going
to have to struggle with in a way that
other generations have never had to
because it end of the right to but these
rights also will will bring out their
own struggles and I mean I see this all
the time and and you know so I think we
all need to be more alert to the
differences that we experience and and
and and and give witness to based on
where we are in history but I think we
also have to understand that you know
what we all have struggles and as a
result we are all struggling people and
that that should be able to elicit a
certain kind of empathy that can sustain
us i think more strongly and more deeply
than it than it currently does